non pas que sa peur et regarde devoir
toujours là avec ces tirs un peu à
gauche benoît sibyllin vont pas faire
trop de regard de yann tora tora toi
encore de ce que tout est ok et après
c'est vrai que pour vous faire une
découverte avec la bretagne vous savez
dans la montagne c'est là vous faites
découverte et vous voit sa [ __ ] me
rappeler
ouais mais pas la fin
enfin pas toujours la vie voilà tu en
sais pas mais voilà lucie un père buteux
c'est assez impressionnant quand même
regard de bordeaux comme ça c'est une
nuit voilà un joli plan affaire a quand
même bon on va pas être trop traîner tu
me fais avec plaisir au jeu
je suis quasi des regards parce que
c'est complet couvrant au jeu pas sur le
foot j'adore
on va découvrir la gym derrière moi
toutes les parades a tempêté 32 face à
toi par là à temps pour apprécier un bon
match car on aura le barrage vous savez
le problème à part les loyers non ça
n'arrive sur la montagne cap ça et on
passe au dessus de ça ouais bah dites
choc visuel premières allaient être
faites et oui oui oui il faut le 10 ans
ils en parleront encore los angeles
attendu à tant de bons paix ok on est
parti sur la gauche maintenant qu'est ce
que tu veux voir le valjoly
ok tu vas voir derrière les touts les
aligner derrière ça que ok on est passé
au dessus d'un portail
voilà c'est bon malgré tout les oliviers
voit la belle ville je suis un peu mais
c'était pas des plus à droite un batteur
celle que subit un petit chose
c'est pas terrible
désolé dans ce cadre
3 dû courir derrière
que quelqu'un fasse beaucoup
alla bout son pari ce vin d'honneur
derrière et c'est fabien delahaye a
malheureusement fait de mieux ça fait
quatre ans n'arrive pas à contrer ce que
je veux dire à ses patrons